you describe your father in the book as
a guy who was a workaholic a classic
workaholic was there anger and
resentment towards your father for not
being available
i think there was at a stage probably in
my late teens
i never met anyone who worked like my
father i mean to this day i worked like
a lunatic but
he was literally seven days a week
the deal with my mother was he'd be home
sunday night at
seven to have dinner with the family
i mean who gets that wow yeah yeah
and then he never showed up at seven uh
i went into politics
i think looking back to get close to him
because all he did was what he
did you want to get to know him you go
into his world
because he's not coming into your world
and i think i started to volunteer in
the campaign to get to know him
and then we work together the rest of
our lives
and we wind up closer than any two
brothers
could wind up because we both did the
same thing for each other think about
how bizarre this is
i'm his campaign manager he wins i then
am his
counselor for 12 years
i then run and he helps me
and then he's my advisor but don't you
think
there's a great sadness in that the
little boy
who has to jump through hoops to earn
his father's
love yes yes
uh and that's why when you said was
there a resentment i think early on
there was a res there was a it was a
hurt right you don't get angry when
you're
a kid you get hurt uh why didn't he
want to do things with me why didn't he
want to take me to the ball game why is
everybody else going in the ball
why didn't we ever take a vacation never
took a vacation never
yeah i'm sure i went through that as it
turns
out he did not really have that
dimension
he did not have that emotional
intimacy and he was from a different
generation
you worked that's what you did that was
the model you go
and you work you know you said in the
book and i found this touching
i sometimes put on my father's shoes you
literally will put on a pair of your
father's shoes when you're having a
difficult day
it's a beautiful thing you put on your
father's shoes but it's also a hungry
thing you know i'm hungry to get
to know my father you will live with
that hunger
forever it does not go away i can say i
understand that intellectually and i
do but we're talking about emotions and
logic doesn't conquer emotions
putting on the shoes is almost
my conscious affirmation of the void
i'm saying yes i feel that void and now
he's gone
and i feel that void even more and
i'm aware of it and i'm so aware of it
that when i need to fill the void i
literally put on his
shoes you know it's not my daughter say
it's subconscious some psychological you
should talk to someone i
said no no i know exactly what it is
i'm saying i miss him
i i miss the i want him with me in this
moment i need his support and his
love in this moment
and i'll put on his shoes as a way to
fill
that void